[Music]
i have something to tell you
and you're very lucky because i've never
told anyone this in my whole life
you ready to make history you say that
every time
i get it's a heck of a view oh it's more
than that maybe it's time we finally
tell somebody else
hey grandpa
i think you two should consider moving
out of the house that's what you're
worried about one of your neighbors saw
you pushing nana around in the middle of
the night but i think they're hiding
something in that [ __ ]
there's a reason
we were the ones who found this
this is our riddle to solve
who are you
do you think he's some kind of alien he
could be dangerous
i think i know how to find him
take care of this
[Music]
i need to see where all this leaves
franklin and i want you there with me
you're always looking for an answer to
life's great mystery
i found mine
here in this house with you
they control everything it's just the
way to protect the secret
there's more of those by the way
a lot more
you